so
last time we discussed the tca cycle
and that allows us to then you know
say how we can take glucose and
completely oxidized
those six glucose carbons into co2 and
you know of course glycolysis converts
glucose into two pyruvate
pyruvate has three carbons and then
pyruvate dehydrogenase can
release the first of those carbons of
co2
generates an acetyl coa that acetyl coa
then enters the tca cycle
and two other co2s are released one at
the isocitrate dehydrogenase step
one at the alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase step
now we discussed that the tca cycle is
useful because it
allows you to oxidize anything that can
be turned into
acetyl coa into co2 and that includes
fatty acids which
we will spend a lot of time talking
about today
now the tca cycle as i mentioned just by
review
is also very useful as a way to make
stuff
lots of useful intermediates but we
discussed last time if we're going to do
that that is
because it functions as a cycle if we
remove some stuff from the cycle
something has to be added back in
so-called anaplerosis
in order to have it continue to function
as a cycle
now you'll note we weren't explicit
about this but this is oxidation
remember carbon oxidation is generally
favorable so delta g of this will be
less than zero
however unlike glycolysis where we
discussed that most of the
you know harnessing of energy that is
the
favorable oxidation of glucose to
pyruvate
was captured to directly keep an atp adp
ratio high in the cell
you can see that most of the energy
output of the tca cycle
isn't actually direct synthesis of atp
or
gtp instead what we have is we have most
of that energy is being captured
in charging up a ratio of nadh to nad
or fadh2 to fad and we'll see over the
next several lectures how we can
harness electron transfer from those
molecules to oxygen
to make atp as well as do some other
work
but before we get to that i want to
first
focus a bit on fat which of course is
the most reduced
carbon biomolecule in the cell and so
that's chains of of
fully reduced carbon
and of course this is the most
chemically dense way to
store energy as as as carbon intuitively
you know this because what's
oil and gas it's chains of reduced
hydrocarbons
of course those are better fuels than
wood which are you know as we saw before
is based on carbohydrate
uh out you know alcohol carbons
you also know intuitively that fat has
more calories than sugar
exactly same ideas and so
i want to start by discussing what
biological fat is
and then that will lead into a
discussion about how we can oxidize the
fat
also as a way to get energy
now most biological fat is packaged into
molecules called
lipids and so i want to make clear that
lipids are not the same thing as fat
more correctly a lipid contains
fat or more precisely something called a
fatty acid
and so what is a fatty acid well it's
this
fully saturated hydrocarbon with a
carboxylic acid
on the end and so we have a
carboxylic acid followed by
some chain of fully saturated
hydrocarbons and so it
differs from oil and gasoline in that it
has this
uh carboxylic acid handle if you will
on the end that basically allows biology
to build and break down
these um these these uh fatty acids
now most biological fatty acids have
even
numbers of carbons
and it turns out that that's a
consequence of the fact that it's built
and broken down
into these two carbon acetyl coa units
and the most common lengths that is how
long
these chains are so in biology they can
vary anywhere from 4 to 36 carbons long
but the most common ones are 12 to 24
carbons
with 16 carbons and 18 carbons being
by far the most abundant in cells
now it's worth mentioning what some of
the names of
these more common ones are because
you'll see them
and so the
fully saturated
16 carbon fatty acids so 16 carbons
total
14 15 16 including the carboxylic acid
this is referred to as palmitate
or it's drawn in the acid form palmitic
acid and the
systematic name for this is hexadecinoic
acid the other common one the 18
carbon version
so same molecule but two carbons longer
that's referred to as steerate
or stearic acid if drawn in the acid
form
or the systematic name would be octa
deca noic
acid now oftentimes
things like palmitate can also be drawn
like this
so there's 16 carbons another way to
draw palmitate
and you'll note that palmitate as well
as stearate here
are fully saturated
what do i mean by saturated i mean
fully saturated by electrons there's no
way to reduce
this molecule further unless of course
we reduce the
the carboxylic acid on the end
and so palmitate would be the most
saturated 16 carbon fatty acid
stearate is the most saturated 18 carbon
fatty acid now
if i add a double bond to
one of these molecules that's an
oxidation
so just like when we added a double bond
to succinate to make fumarate in the tca
cycle
i showed that last time that's an
oxidation reaction
and so an unsaturated fatty acid
is a fatty acid that is no longer fully
saturated with electrons that mean it is
not
fully reduced and so remember you store
energy as reduced carbon
and so an unsaturated fatty acid stores
less
energy than a saturated fatty acid
because it's more oxidized than the
saturated
fatty acid and so this is a couple
examples here so here's the
example of a 16 carbon
unsaturated fatty acid
so i introduce a double bond
i'll draw it in the fatty and the acid
form here and so here you got
5 6 7 8 plus seven is fifteen
sixteen carbons total one double bond
this is palmito
leic acid
more systematically named hexa
design
acid and the 18-carbon version
would be as follows
okay so i added two extra carbons on
this end of the molecule this is oleic
acid
or octa
dassinolic
acid
now note i put a double bond in here
you'll remember from
organic chemistry that double bonds can
exist
in a trans or a cis
form and so if it's trans
it would be like this if it's cis
the double bond would be
like that in the carbon chain
and so just to show you here on the
models that this
can matter so here's a double bonded
carbon
and so these two red guys are cis to
each other
and this purple is trans to that now if
i put this
onto a fatty acid chain you can see that
there's
a big difference there so if i add
the double bond in here and it's
continue the chain
here on a transbond it's a relatively
straight molecule
whereas if i go here in a cis bond i now
introduce a kink
into the alkyl chain so
biological fatty acids are always
cis and this is structurally important
because it actually creates
this kink in fatty acids that are
not fully saturated now
obviously as you might guess the number
of double bonds and the locations of the
double bonds
will change the structure and therefore
the properties of the fatty acids
and so we need a nomenclature that
allows us to
describe what's going on here and so
the simplest nomenclature is as follows
where we basically
have the number of carbons and the fatty
acids say
18 followed by the number
of double bonds okay so an 18
1 fatty acid that's oleic
acid so 18 carbons long one double bond
18 0 would be steric
acid 18 carbons long zero double bonds
16 0 palmitate palmitic acid
16 carbons long zero double bonds
so if we have one double bond
oftentimes this is referred to as a mufa
or mono
unsaturated
fatty acid and of course if i have many
double bonds more than one that's a pufa
or a poly unsaturated
fatty acid probably heard those terms
so what's an example of a
polyunsaturated fat
fatty acid well
a common one is an 18 2
polyunsaturated fatty acids 18 carbons 2
double bonds
the common biological one is called
linoleic
acid and
ch3
ok and so
one two double bonds four five six seven
eight nine ten seventeen eighteen
carbons total
eighteen two fatty acid linoleic
acid formal name is octa
deca diene
acid okay that make it more unsaturated
so in 18 3
okay that is
linolenic acid
or octa deca
triene noec
acid and i
painfully draw out the
entire thing
so we got one two three double bonds
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten seventeen eighteen carbons total
eighteen three um polyunsaturated fatty
acid with
three double bonds in it in all of these
cases all of those double bonds
are cis double bonds and you'll also
notice
that the spacing
of them is not
entirely random either at least as i
drew it
the first of all is that these are not
conjugated double bonds so you see that
there's
a carbon in all cases between the double
bond
and also you'll notice that most of the
double bonds are actually started
and if you count from this end from the
carb from from the acid end
this would be carbon 9 and 10 so 1 plus
7 is 8
9 10. each of them the first double bond
i put in is
between carbons 9 and 10 going in this
direction
and that's a consequence of the
conserved enzymes that introduce these
double bonds into the molecule
now obviously this spacing
matters um and so we need a way in the
nomenclature in order to
denote that that is where exactly the
double bonds are
located and there's sort of two ways we
can count we can count from one end or
we can count from the other end
now the most systematic way
uh correct way now is to count from the
carboxylic acid end so very similar to
sugars we counted carbon one of sugars
to be
the one that was closest to the end of
the molecule where the
carbonyl was located so same thing in
fatty acids so this would be carbon one
count in that direction and so the
nomenclature would be then to put in a
delta
nine would be a double bond between the
ninth
and tenth carbon counting from the
carboxylic acid
and so the 18
2 fatty acid i drew here linoleic acid
would more precisely be 18
2 delta 9 delta 12 that's because it's
carbon 9
10 11 12. so carbon 9 and 10
and 12 and 13. linolenic acid
18 3 delta 9 12
15 so 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 to say
where the double bonds are in the
polyunsaturated fatty acids as you can
see most polyunsaturated fatty acids as
a consequence that they're not
conjugated
are placed every you'll see that the
double bonds are placed every three
carbons
now this three carbon spacing
is maintained even in the
often in biology even in the exceptions
where
the first one is not between carbon 9
and 10 and so
a classic example of that is the
polyunsaturated fatty acid arachidonic
acid
which is
a 20 carbon fatty acid with four double
bonds at carbons 5
8 11 and 14. so arachidonic acid
you may have heard in the past is a key
signaling fatty acid
it's mobilized and used to generate some
inflammatory mediators it's the enzyme
that
acts on this to generate the
inflammatory mediators is the target
of very common drugs like the like
aspirin
or other non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs
ibuprofen etc and this molecule drawing
it like this
should fully describe to you what it
would look like all right
now there's also an older nomenclature
that numbers fatty acids to name them
and where the double bonds are located
not from the carbonyl side but from the
other end of the molecule and i
mentioned this nomenclature because it's
still
used quite often in popular culture
and so to do this it's basically refers
to
this i guess as the alpha carbon so
counting in greek
going this direction the final carbon
in the fatty acid omega the last letter
of the greek
alphabet and so if you count from the
other end we could also give this
a a different nomenclature
and so in this case our 18 3
lino lay our 18 3 linolenic acid 183
delta 9 12
15 we could also say is 18
3 omega
three six nine so now we're counting
from this
end one two three first double the bond
four five six next double bond seven 8 9
next double bond and so
thus 18 1 by this nomenclature
18 1 delta 9 would be the same as
18 1 omega 9
because it's obviously meeting in the
middle but if we did 18
1 delta 12
that would be 18 1 omega 6 18
1 delta 15 would be 18 1
omega 3. and so i mentioned this because
you'll hear about so-called omega-3
fatty acids
the major omega-3 fatty acid that
they're talking about
is linolenic acid and it's an omega-3
fatty acid using the nomenclature
counting from the other side
or you could also say it's 18 3 delta 9
12
15. now i want to mention one of the
reasons you hear about omega-3 fatty
acids is that
in general these are there are fatty
acids such as those that humans cannot
make
and so we have to get those from the
diets and so this is the concept called
essential
fatty acids and so somewhat like
vitamins there's
things out there that our physiology
uses that we have to get
from other organisms making and
therefore we have to
eat them and so if you hear this term
essential fatty acid
it's basically referring to specific
fatty acids where we lack the enzymes
to place all the double bonds um
to be in the place where it's useful for
for some
aspect of our our biology
all right now lots of nomenclature here
nature the reason i discuss this is
because
this diversity of chain length and
double bonds
creates different properties and nature
uses these diverse
chemical properties of the fatty acids
that is different change lengths and
different degrees of saturation or
unsaturation
positions of the of of the double bonds
to
take advantage of those properties to do
different things
in biology and so a lot of this has to
do
a lot of why fatty acids are useful is
that they are not
soluble in water or poorly soluble in
water
you know this just from the common
experience of making salad dressing
and so you mix the oil and the vinegar
in the salad dressing and so the
oil is largely made out of fatty acids
made out of lipids
and those fatty acids are not soluble
soluble in the vinegar part the water
part of the molecule
okay now the fatty acid themselves
the chain length and the number of
double bonds
will affect other properties such as the
melting temperature
so in general the melting
temperature of a fatty acid
will decrease with shorter
chain length
and decrease with
more unsaturation so
more double bonds so the more double
bonds i put in and the shorter it is
the lower the melting temperature
and so you guys know this from just
cooking experience
um to be the case and so
animal fatty acids
tend to be more saturated
and because they're more saturated they
have a
higher melting temperature and so their
solids at room temperature
so think about it animal fat butter lard
these things are solids at room
temperature
so plant fatty acids
they tend to be more
unsaturated
fatty acids and they're liquids at room
temperature
and you know this because cooking oil
made from plants
is typically a liquid at room
temperature
now you might be aware that olive oil is
a mono unsaturated it has a lot of
monounsaturated fatty acids a lot of
mufas
olive oil unlike other plant oils which
are more polyunsaturated fatty acids if
you put those in the refrigerator
the olive oil will tend to form a solid
whereas your canola oil will not and
that's a consequence of the fact that
the
more unsaturated fatty acids there are
the
um lower the melting temperature and so
the more likely it is to be a liquid or
a salad
in the fridge or at room temperature
across these
different fatty acids to show here on
the slide here's just
something i stole from the textbook it
basically gives the
composition of some things you might be
aware of so olive oil butter
and beef fat so you can see as we go
down the spectrum here
you have um longer chain lengths
and a reduction in the number of double
bonds
and of course b fat if you've ever
handled it is
a much firmer solid at room temperature
than butter is which is of course
solid at room temperature whereas olive
oil
is not and that follows this with the
number the chain length and the double
bonds really affecting the melting
temperature
of these different fats just a couple of
sides so you can better
understand your food and so you may have
heard about or seen on the side of your
food packaging
hydrogenated
oils so what's a hydrogenated
oil well that's basically taking a plant
oil
which has unsaturated unsaturated fatty
acids
and hydrogen hydrogenating it that is
adding hydrogen
well what is that it's not really the
hydrogen that's being added it's adding
electrons so it's taking it from being
a unsaturated fatty acid to chemically
making it a saturated fatty acid
and it's a way to take plant oils and
make it such that it's solid at room
temperature
an example of a hydrogenated oil would
be margarine
okay plant oil that would be liquid
reduce it chemically such that it's
fully saturated
and now it's a solid at room temperature
sure you've also heard of so-called
trans fats so what's a trans fat other
than something
cooked up in the devil's kitchen so
trans fats are basically taking
animal fat and introducing chemically
double bonds
into them such that you have this solid
that is now a liquid
at room temperature now this is done
chemically to introduce those double
bonds and so if you're introducing a
double bond chemically
by oxidizing the fatty acid you'll get
some cis and some trans
cis is what biology does because it
introduces them with an enzyme
trans versus cis is not controlled when
it's done chemically
and so this leads to these unnatural
trans fatty acids which
lead to health issues and are now banned
in many cities including here in
cambridge massachusetts
right last aside is is all of us have
probably experienced
are oils or fats going rancid
so what is that so that's oxygen
oxidizing
the the fatty acid and so if you want to
protect your oil from going rancid the
thing to do is just keep it
sealed right keep oxygen away from it
and your oil will last
a lot longer okay so
that's fatty acids in biology
most fatty acids aren't sitting around
by themselves
they're esterified to an alcohol and
as we mentioned in an earlier lecture a
lipid
equals a fatty acid
that's esterified
to an alcohol
all right so we spent some time in the
prior lecture
talking about doing this to make
phospholipids all right and that's an
example
of a lipid fatty acids esterified to
make this
um this phospholipid which gave us both
a polar and a nonpolar end
and allowed us to create membranes and
so lipids have lots of
important functions in cells and so
there's the
barrier function which was basically
membranes things like phospholipids we
talked about last time
there's also signaling functions
of lipids so i mentioned arachidonic
acid
earlier you'll certainly encounter
signaling
functions of lipids and other courses
and then the last one which is really
the reason why we talk about it now is
lipids are great for energy storage
because it's the most um reduced
carbon so the most dense way to store
energy as reduced carbon
so the simplest lipid
and the one used for energy storage is
referred to
as a
triacyl glyceride often abbreviated
as a tag triacylglyceride
and we can see now how we can make a
triacylglyceride
as well as how it relates to other
pathways in
metabolism that we've encountered and so
here's our
old friend from glycolysis
hopefully you recognize this molecule as
the phosphorylated triose
dihydroxyacetone
phosphate also an intermediate in
glycolysis
and so if we
reduce this ketone to
the alcohol
so two electrons from nad plus
nadh um reduce that
ketone that'll oxidize the nadh to nad
plus
if we also remove the phosphate now what
do we have
now we have the alcohol
and this molecule is
glycerol all right and so now this
glycerol as we talked about before
we can take three fatty acids esterify
them to
each of those alcohols
okay and now we have a
glycerol molecule with three fatty acid
uh three fatty acids esterified to the
alcohols
on the glycerol this is a
dry acyl glyceride now of course
triacclycerides are not soluble in water
and so when we make these in cells
for energy storage they're
stored as so-called lipid droplets and
so
if you look here at the slide here's an
example this up here
is an adipocyte from an animal this down
here i think is a plant
cell and so in both cases
you have these large
droplets that would be basically
droplets of
triacylglycerides that basically form as
a way for
long-term energy storage and so while we
think of at least as people our
adipocytes are fat cells as storing our
fat they do
but they're really specialized cell
types that have these
giant lipid droplets whereas many cells
actually have much smaller lipid
droplets as a way to
store um store tricylglycerides as a way
to store
energy as reduced carbon
all right i also want to say that if you
look at this
unlike the phospholipids that we
described earlier
as ways to build membranes these don't
have a charge on them and so they're
sometimes referred to
as so-called neutral
lipids and it's really this neutral
lipids that allow them to
clump together in these oil particles if
you will these lipid droplets in cells
that are good for energy storage
now why specifically are neutral lipids
good for energy storage well
really chemically dense way to store
energy the most reduced carbon
and by forming these droplets
okay not unlike the oil in your salad
dressing and other
neutral lipid forming droplets within
the vinegar
this is a way that you store reduced
carbon without having to carry around
water and so if we store energy as
carbohydrates
starch or glycogen these molecules
have to exist in water so you're
carrying around the starch and glycogen
but as an animal we're also carrying
around the water
if we're carrying around reduced carbon
as
lipids we can now exclude the water from
it
and so it's much more dense and we can
in a more efficient way
carry around this um this material
without having to carry the water and so
gram for gram
fat is a much more efficient way to
pack on calories that we can burn later
than storing it as carbohydrate
fat's also nice because it forms a nice
insulator
and so it makes sense as animals we need
to survive the winter
pack on all kinds of calories as fat
don't have to carry around as water
just have the energy there is reduce
carbon and then we can slowly release it
over the course of the winter where
we as well as use it to keep us warm and
then
um build up those stores again during
the summer months when there's when
there's more food
available fat of course has months worth
of
energy packed into it whereas
carbohydrates that we carry around our
glycogen
has less than a day's worth of energy so
we could live off of our fat for
the winter we can't live off of our
glycogen for
the winter now the big trade-off here is
that it's much slower to mobilize fat
we have to get into these lipid droplets
and break off
little pieces of it get them into
aqueously water-soluble
pieces to break it down um glycogen of
course is already
in water can break it down much faster
and so it's much slower to mobilize the
fat
but it can be much uh more efficient in
terms of what's stored
whereas uh glycogen can be mobilized a
lot faster
and that's really part of our physiology
you will burn your glycogen first
when you exercise before you start
burning a lot of fat and i think many
have heard about that from just reading
and thinking about
what you know about exercise physiology
okay now again i want to make the point
that we all know that fat has more
calories
than sugar and the reason for that is to
be clear
is because it's more reduced and so the
energy that's released from burning fat
just like the energy that's released
from burning sugar
comes because the transfer of electrons
from the reduced hydrocarbon to oxygen
is favorable and that is how energy is
released
and so fat is more reduced than sugar
and so
more electrons to transfer
and so more energy released than burning
sugar
all right so now let's go through in a
pathway sense
how does nature rather than taking
gasoline and just igniting it and
releasing a lot of energy
how does nature stepwise break down
fatty acids in a way that that energy
release can be controlled
in the same way we described it for
carbohydrates
glycolysis in the tca cycle controlled
stepwise energy release that can be
captured to do things like
make it atp okay um
how is the same thing work for oxidation
of
fatty acids well if as organisms
we store fatty acids in these
triacylglycerides or other
neutral lipids the first step is we have
to
get them out of the neutral lipids
and so if we start with a
triacylglyceride
the first step is to use a lipase
molecule so a lipase just breaks that
ester bond and so you basically now have
glycerol
plus the three fatty acids
we're going to spend most our time
most of our time today discussing how
you break down the fatty acids
however i want to mention should be
clear how you're also going to
metabolize the glycerol
so glycerol we can oxidize
the glycerol
okay so now if we oxidize that
alcohol what are we going to get we're
going to get
dihydroxyacetone and then if we
phosphorylate one of the ends of
that with atp now we get
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and that of
course can go into
glycol
glycolysis generate pyruvate generate
seo coa
oxidize that oxidal coa in the tca cycle
get energy from the glycerol part of of
the lipid
all right so what about oxidizing
the fatty acids well the first thing
we have to talk about to oxidize the
fatty acids is
where is this going to occur in the cell
and so
lipid droplets are floating out there in
the cell
and so you mobilize these pieces
with the lipase well the glycerol now is
sitting there in the cytosol
that can form dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and be burned in glycolysis which is in
the cytosol
but once we generate that pyruvate
remember that pyruvate had to get into
the mitochondria
where we turned it into acetyl-coa so
the acetyl-coa was present in the
mitochondrial matrix
so that is here in the matrix of the
mitochondria
where the tca cycle happens so remember
glycolysis in the cytosol
tca cycle in the matrix and so that
pyruvate needed to get into the matrix
so we could turn it into acetyl-coa and
then that acetyl-coa was in the right
place
to generate um to be entered into the
tca cycle
and turned into co2
well fatty acid oxidation has the same
thing and so if those fatty acids are
generated out here in the cytosol when
their
lipases remove them from the lipid
droplet it turns out
we're going to burn the acetyl coa we
get from the bake breakdown of the fatty
acids
that acetyl coa needs to be in the
matrix so it has access to the tca cycle
and so we're going to get we need to get
the fatty acid from the cytosol
inside the mitochondria now part of this
remember
our coe group that i drew last time is
this giant molecule
and so acetyl coa is not this little
two-carbon unit it's this big giant
molecule
and so by generating the acetyl-coa in
the mitochondria we obviate the need to
get this giant coa group across
the mitochondrial membranes but of
course we do need to get the fatty acid
into the right location as well
and so the way that that fatty acid is
transported there
is actually via a system called the
carnitine
shuttle but there's sort of a little bit
of a roundabout way to do it and that is
we are going to need to do two things
get the fatty acid
inside the mitochondria as well as
activate it
with this coenzyme
a group and
it turns out that the fatty acid is
first
activated in the cytosol by adding
the coenzyme a group to the acid on the
end
very much like acetyl coa and so
here is
some generic chain length
fatty acid and it turns out that there's
an enzyme
called acyl co-asynthetase
that is going to take
atp
and adenylate
this acid group on
the fatty acid
okay and so this is basically
an amp that's been used to adenylate
the fatty acid itself
now you'll notice by doing this we
generate a pyrophosphate
and that pyrophosphate can be turned
into two inorganic phosphates
same trick we've seen before that
basically can pull
a reaction that otherwise would be
unfavorable forward in this case
it's adding the co-a group
to this fatty acid and
what happens next is is that uh
co-a comes in and replaces the amp
such that you generate this
fatty acyl
coa molecule which is basically acetyl
coa
but with some arbitrary longer
number of of reduced hydrocarbons
in the chain so not a two carbon unit
but a fatty acid a many carbon unit
fatty acid with whatever
other properties happen to be on that
fatty acid
where now you have this fatty acyl coa
instead of
the fatty acid so it turns out this
fatty acyl coa then
is subjected to a shuttle called the
carnitine shuttle
to actually get it into the mitochondria
and so what is carnitine
so carnitine is a
small molecule looks like this
okay so this here is carnitine
and it turns out that this hydroxyl
group
basically is swapped for the koa
on the fatty acyl coa and so if this
here is some
generic fatty acyl coated
you end up with this molecule which is
called
a fatty acyl
carnitine so all i've done is take the
coa off
and move the fatty acid to make this
ester here with the alcohol on the
carnitine and this
fatty acyl carnitine can now be
transported across
the mitochondrial membrane so from the
cytosol to the mitochondria
here we have our fatty acyl
carnitine and then that fatty acyl
carnitine exchange
a coa
for the carnitine and regenerate the
fatty acyl
coa in the mitochondrial matrix
this whole process is referred to as the
carnitine shuttle and is effectively a
complex way
to move fatty acids from the cytosol
fatty acyl coas from the cytosol into
the mitochondria where they can be
oxidized
here's another picture of it that is
maybe drawn in a
different way because it's a little bit
confusing as something to describe but
basically you generate
this fatty acyl coa
in the um in the cytosol
and then the fatty acyl coa is
exchanged for fatty acyl carnitine fatty
acyl carnitine goes into the matrix and
these used to regenerate the
fatty acyl coa the enzymes that do this
is something called cpt or carnitine
palmitoel
transferase um
and write that down
carnitine
which is obviously refers to palmitate
as a common
fatty acid although cpt will catalyze
many
fatty acyl carnitine fatty acyl coa
interconversions
and so by doing that inner conversion in
the cytosolic side and the mitochondrial
side
you can use carnitine as a handle to
transfer
fatty acyl coast from one compartment to
another all right
now once that fatty acyl coa is in the
mitochondria
it can now be used as a way
to now be oxidized to acetyl-coa
okay so now let's discuss the series of
steps
that is referred to as fatty acid
oxidation
and abbreviated fao and so of course we
start here with our
generic fatty acyl
coa in the matrix of the mitochondria
of some arbitrary
chain length okay and so
the first thing that we're going to do
is
oxidize this carbon-carbon bond that is
introduce a double bond here
that's an oxidation reaction it's
exactly the same reaction
that we saw convert succinate to
fumarate
in the tca cycle that reaction
used fad
as an electron acceptor so we oxidize
that carbon-carbon bond
fad gets reduced to fadh2
this is carried out by an enzyme called
acyl
coa dehydrogenase
and generates that intermediate
again now just like we did in the tca
cycle when we converted
fumarate into malate we added water
across
this double bond to exactly
the same thing here
okay that generates this intermediate
now we can oxidize this
carbon here this alcohol oxidize it to
the ketone of course you know how
to do this we've now seen it a million
times
okay so that generates this
hydride ion which can be
transferred to nad plus
reducing it to nadh
okay and now we can
what happens next is co-a
basically breaks that carbon-carbon bond
and what are we left with we're left
with over here release of
a acetyl
coa group which can then go down and be
further oxidized
in the tca cycle as well as
this
fatty acyl coa
that is two carbon shorter than
the one we started with
that can then go back up
repeat the cycle again until
if you start with an even number of
carbons the last one leaves you with
two acetyl coa molecules
and so per two carbon units that we run
through this cycle of fatty acid
oxidation what we get is we get
an acetyl coa it comes out
we get an fadh2
and we get on nadh
now of course if we start with an
unsaturated fatty acid
we don't have to introduce the double
bond into it we don't get the fadh2
we get less energy produced
um from that molecule
and so if this acetyl coa goes on and
enters the tca cycle
well then we get and we fully oxidize it
to co2
we get three more nadh we get another
fadh2
and we get a gtp it's written up there
as a reminder
and so with a fully saturated
per two carbons out we basically get
four nadhs two fadh2s and a gdp
and that's a fair amount of energy
if you will released from the oxidation
of this fatty acid all the way to
co2 we'll come back to that accounting
in a second but first i want to say what
happens if you happen to start
with an odd number of carbons so i
mentioned that most biological fatty
acids have even numbers of carbons
but there are odd chain numbers of
odd chain carbon lengths of fatty acids
some bacteria make these sometimes it
just happens obviously if you do that
you'll end up at the end with this
molecule
which is a three carbon acyl coa called
propionil
coa
and so cells need a way to deal with
this three carbon propineal coa
well the way they deal with it is they
carboxylate it
so we're going to add a co2 to a
molecule how do we do that well we need
a cofactor
remember we did this with the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction this was
the reaction of biotin
so we started with bicarbonate we
phosphorylated
the bicarbonate
and then that phosphorylated bicarbonate
there was biotin in the active site of
the enzyme
that released the phosphate they had
enzyme biotin
with a co2 on it and so
if we take this propyneal coa here which
is drawn in the
enol form i mean sorry in the keto form
and we redraw it in the
enol form of the
propanil coa
we carry out similar reaction that we
saw before
and now we end up with this molecule
so effectively adding the co2 to this
carbon
to the second carbon in and that's this
molecule
which is called methyl
malianil coe
i'm going to redraw methylmalonyl coa
just to show you how cells deal
with this
okay so this is methylmalonyl coa i just
redrew it in a way that there's some
colors on the different
molecules what i'm going to do is i'm
basically going to take this group
and this group and swap their
positions um and if i do that
i will end up with
this molecule which hopefully you
recognize as
succinal coa from the tca cycle
now the mechanism for how that swap
happens i don't have
time to go into but this complex
intramolecular rearrangement requires
a cofactor that cofactor comes from
vitamin b12
and so here's a picture of vitamin b12
you can see by looking at it why i don't
want to draw that out for you
it's a cobalt containing cofactor
sometimes referred to as cobalamin
if you're interested you can look up the
chemistry for how
vitamin b12 helps catalyze this
intramolecular rearrangement to go from
methylmalonyl coa to succinyl coa
but the important take home is is that
if you have an odd chain fatty acid
use a biotin containing enzyme to
carboxylate propyneal coa
to methylmalonyl coa and then b12 to
rearrange that methylmalonyl coa to
suctional coa
and now this can enter the tca cycle and
be oxidized
as well all right so
now you have the details of how you can
start
with a fatty acid and
oxidize it to co2
now i think it's useful if we compare
the output of what we can get from
glucose oxidation to co2 carbohydrate
oxidation to co2
to what we can get if we start with a
fatty acid
and oxidize it to co2 and sort of
illustrate
that there are more calories in fat than
there are
in sugar and so for this comparison
we'll start we'll compare glucose
which of course has six carbons
in it to a
six zero fatty acid also six
carbons and what do we get if we take
this
less reduced versus more reduced
molecule
and fully oxidize it to co2
all right well if we start with glucose
so if we take that glucose and we run
glycolysis
and so take that glucose and turn it
into
two pyruvate molecules of course we get
from that
two atps and two
[Music]
nadhs and then if we take those
two pyruvate molecules and turn them
into
two acetyl coas
plus two co2s that's the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction
we get two more nadhs
and then if we take those two acetyl
coas
and turn them into four co2s
that's the tca cycle what do we get out
we get two
gtp molecules
we get um
two fadh2
molecules from the succinate
dehydrogenase step
and we get two times three equals six
more
nadhs and so our
total yield is four
atp equivalents remember the gtps can be
interconverted with atp
two fadh2s
and six
seven eight nine ten
nadhs all right what if we start with
our
six zero fatty acid
well to metabolize
it first we have to take that fatty acid
and we have to make
our fatty acyl coa that's going to cost
us
two atp y2 atp
because remember when we charge that
fatty acyl coa
which is now erased i think yes it is
um we converted an atp to an amp
and so that's two atp equivalents to
charge that
fatty acid to a fatty acyl coa
next we take that fatty acyl coa
and we turn it into three
acetyl coa molecules via
fatty acid oxidation cycle that's
two trips around to generate
the three acetyl coas so that'll give us
two fadh2s and two
nadhs all right
and then once we have those three acetyl
coas
we can turn them into six co2s in the
tca cycle
so that's three gtps three
fadh2s and three times three is nine
nadhs for a total
yield of three minus two is
one atp equivalent
eleven sorry
five fadh2
and 11 nadhs
all right now
i went through this exercise because
it's not immediately apparent that the
yield of fatty acid oxidation
gives you more energy from full
oxidation
than oxidizing the equivalent
carbohydrate
at least in terms of atp you get four
atps directly from
full oxidation of glucose whereas you
only get one
atp equivalent directly from the
complete oxidation
of this six carbon fatty acid
coa now i say this because
most of the energy if you will that's
released
from oxidation of fat and sugar isn't
actually directly producing
atp it's actually being used to charge
up
this nadh
nad plus or fadh2
fad ratios in the cell
which we will see is
also a lot of energy because those
electrons can be transferred
to oxygen and be used to do other work
down the road now
your book will tell you that each of
these nadhs or fadh2s
are worth on the order of one to three
atp
and i guess this kind of fits
intuitively what you might guess based
on the thermodynamics of the gap dh
reaction so if you go back to that
remember
our oxidative phosphorylation we
described at gap dh
roughly generated an atp
okay and so even if
we say one atp equals an fadh2 or an
nadh which
of course there's not a direct
relationship to that
you can still even with that say that
our fatty acid oxidation if we add up
all these numbers
we would get you know 17
whereas if we add up all these numbers
we get 16.
so i guess that says that there's more
coming from fatty acid oxidation than
from
uh complete glucose oxidation but you
probably also learned in high school or
somewhere else that
nadh gives you more atp than fadh2
that's true our goal is to understand
why that's the case
and so you'll actually those numbers
will only get better
for fatty acid oxidation in terms of atp
equivalence
when we can describe how to do those
conversions however to really appreciate
how these electron carriers equal
energy and equal biological energy we
really need to go back
and revisit some concepts
in bioenergetics and thermodynamics
to really understand what biological
energy is
and that'll also help us understand
mitochondrial oxidative phosphorylation
which is really the process that allows
us to
interconvert these
electron carriers and their ability to
transfer electrons to oxygen
as a way to
generate favorably synthesized atp
okay so hopefully you will remember
from our previous lectures that for any
reaction
any pathway any process to occur
it has to be thermodynamically favorable
that is delta g has to be less than zero
and remember atp to adp was useful
because that reaction is very favorable
and so we could couple
atp to adp conversion to otherwise
unfavorable reactions
and that is what allowed us to have atp
be useful
and it was useful because delta g equals
delta g
naught prime plus rt times the log
of the products of the reaction
over the reactants of the reaction
and so if adp is a product
an atp is a reactant it was actually
that atp adp ratio
that was providing the energy if you
will to
drive the reaction
all right this was also
if you recall why we described that
oxidation of reduced carbon
because it was favorable was able to be
coupled to reactions that keep this atp
adp ratio high
so that that high ratio could then
support
otherwise unfavorable reactions
but now you hopefully appreciate that in
reality
most of the energy
from carbon oxidation is not directly
captured as atp
it's being used to charge up these other
ratios
nad nadh fad
and the energetics of doing that follow
exactly the same rules as atp or really
any other reaction
okay and effectively it's the transfer
of electrons
that is favorable or not that really
is going on here
just like we discussed for
atp to adp and so we can couple other
reactions to those ratios as a way to
make
other reactions possible
now ultimately it turns out that these
things these redox ratios are more
useful than atp
because these electron transfers
favorable electron transfers
remember biological energy is all about
oxidation and reduction
can be used to drive atp we'll see that
when we described how oxfos
in the mitochondria really works but it
can be used for other things as well
we'll see we can use it to make heat we
can do it other work like move ions etc
and so we can even make glucose right
gluconeogenesis we needed a source of
nadh
and so ultimately all biological energy
of course has to come from the sun and
photosynthesis
also is about capturing solar energy as
these oxidation and reduction pairs
and so if we
appreciate this what we realize is that
it's really these transfers of electrons
remember there's no free electrons in
biology
and so it's really coupling oxidation
and reduction reactions that are
favorable
that ends up being how bioenergetics
largely works now i like to be explicit
about this because sometimes people get
confused by oxidation and reduction
reactions and focus on
charge and i just want to point out
oxidation and reduction reactions are
really
moving electrons and this is
irrelevant of
charge okay so i add an electron to an
uncharged molecule i get a negatively
charged molecule add it to a positively
charged molecule get a neutral molecule
add it to a more positively charged
molecule now i have a positively charged
molecule it's adding these electrons
each of these are reduction reactions
in that direction they would be
oxidation reactions
and so nad plus plus
two electrons going to nadh
fad plus two electrons
going to fad h2
all reductions in this direction all
oxidations
in that direction now because there's
not free electrons these react
these reactions have to happen in pairs
and so
if we consider a pair here's lactate
inner conversion with pyruvate
so alcohol and lactate to the
ketone and pyruvate this direction is an
oxidation
that means the electrons have to go
somewhere
nad plus to nadh
this is a reduction we go from pyruvate
to lactate
that's a reduction we can re-oxidize
nadh
back to nad plus of course you'll
remember from
glycolysis fermentation this inner
conversion is
catalyzed by ldh and effectively
if you're going to use lactate for
energy so we oxidize the lactate
generate nadh we're going to use it for
fermentation
we produce lactate re-oxidize the nadh
nadh back to nad plus
how does ldh know which direction to go
in
how does any reaction any pathway know
which direction to go in
it's delta g delta g equals delta g
naught prime plus rt
times the log of in this case the
pyruvate lactate ratio
times the nadh nad plus ratio
and so how oxidized or reduced
nad plus nadh is will determine
how oxidized and reduced the pyruvate
lactate
ratio is in other words
this must be true for absolutely any
redox pair
and in general remember carbon oxidation
is favorable
and that's because oxidizing carbon
to give those electrons to something
downstream ultimately oxygen
is favorable that's really what's
driving
each of these pathways
now how favorable any of this is of
course can be quantified
and if we want to know this for this
redox pair or any redox pair
of course this is related to some
equilibrium constant and we've already
discussed that we can
have this term delta g not prime that is
relevant to the equilibrium constant but
it's still because delta g determines
what happens it's still that equilibrium
constant
plus the ratios of the reactants and
products that will really determine if
the reaction happens
however it turns out it's useful to
think about
when electrons can go to donated or
accepted in lots of different
reactions it's useful to come up with a
term that helps us know
what is the propensity of an individual
pair
to accept or donate an electron in
either direction and we have a term
for this it's denoted e naught prime
which is the standard
reduction potential
that basically describes for a pair of
molecules
nad plus nadh pyruvate and lactate
in an oxidation or reduction reaction
how likely
is it to give up its electrons in one
direction
or the other and so the units of this is
volts and the standard reduction
potential
can be calculated as follows and of
course it's related to the
equilibrium constant of a
reaction and so the equilibrium constant
of a reaction delta g not prime related
to the equilibrium constant
is this formula n is the number of
electrons transferred
f is the faraday constant and delta
e naught prime is the change
in standard reduction potential from
election
or from electron donation from one pair
to the next pair
all right so if we use our lactate
pyruvate example
okay we have
lactate going to
pyruvate plus two electrons
so that's the electron donor it's being
oxidized and then you have nad
plus plus
the electrons going to nadh
it's being reduced two electrons of
course
it's being reduced and so this
has a standard reduction potential
this half reaction has a standard
reduction potential and so the
difference
between these standard reduction
potentials
that is who receives the electrons
delta e naught prime 2 minus
delta e naught prime 1 gives us
this change in standard reduction
potential
which i can plug into this formula
which is related to the equilibrium
constant and tells me
which direction of electron transfer
is going to be favored at least at
equilibrium
and so if this number
is related to equilibrium there's a
negative here
and so if this term is
positive delta g not prime will be
negative
and that means that electron transfer
will be favored at equilibrium
if this number is negative that means
the reverse
electron transfer will be favored at
equilibrium
and so it stands to reason then
that electron transfer
from smaller
standard reduction potential to larger
standard reduction potentials will be
favored hopefully that makes sense
so smaller to larger now that could be
less uh more negative to less negative
negative to positive positive to more
positive
as long as that delta
is positive electron transfer
will be favored now of course the
ratios still matter okay
but this standard reduction potential is
useful
because it can help us know which
direction transfer
wants to occur between any redox pairs
at equilibrium and so
recognizing this you must know that
carbon oxidation electron transfer
in general is going to be favored to
nadh uh to to nad to make nadh
and in general that nad elect nadh
electron transfer is going to be favored
to oxygen
and it's coupling those favorable
electron transfers
that ultimately is allowing the system
to use oxidation and reduction reactions
to drive these various pathways
and that that energy release from these
electron
transfer reactions can be used to make
atp
and do other work as we will talk about
in great detail in the next lecture